the importance of theology in both
conflict and in reconciliation and I was
wondering if we were describing how if
religion is to play a peaceful role in
these sorts of conflicts people need to
understand the theology behind it I was
wondering if you could speak
specifically to your theology of
reconciliation I think there's nothing
more destructive than bad theology
fundamentalism from wherever it comes is
the most destructive force in our world
today be it a political fundamentalism
or they just fundamentalism the most
destructive force in our world today and
we have some very strange coat theology
on coat because something I don't want
to dignify some of this stuff goes her
ID as theology because to me theology is
a very pure science on but I mean some
very perverse theology upon which people
build their political and other ideas on
ideologies when one is the chosen people
theology and it's not peculiar to
Northern Ireland I was in Texas last
October Alec and I were allegan I Worth
Texas last October and on our breakfast
table there was a milk carton and our
milk was provided for us by the promised
land dairies and on the bottom of the
milk carton was a text from Deuteronomy
this is the land that God gave us now
you take that out of context you put
that on your book cartons and you start
thinking if you're you know a Scottish
Protestants settler in Northern Ireland
this is the lamb God give your identity
then they shaped and formed by what you
see be a biblical theological
justifiable and you become like the
dutch reformed in south africa and for
you know where you are you've built a
thiol
j to suit yourself from convenience so
bothered but good theology let me give
you an example of what I mean by good
theology sometimes we get good theology
from secular sources which is very
important to remind us who profess faith
you remember in the good friday
agreement to one of the things that was
agreed very reluctantly by some was that
there should be an early release of
prisoners that was extremely difficult
to people on both sides nationalists and
unionists who were law-abiding people
and amongst the people who had great
difficulty with this early release of
prisoners were people from the churches
and i thought i was involved in an
organization that was to do with the
care and resettlement of prisoners and i
invited them to come for a dinner dolls
get people on a meeting because of a
dinner and so they came and i invited
them to meet with a man called brian
Curran you will know brand Karen came
out of South Africa brand karen was
involved very much in the truth and
reconciliation condition South Africa
and the whole issue of reparation Center
and I asked him to come and talk about
from the South African experiences what
they did with prisoners and he cleaned
it and somebody from Rhonda table said
but mr. Curran where is their justice
and all of this you know netting like
people have done Helius things early
where is the justice and he said we're
not talking about justice here this
isn't about justice you cannot go to our
widow or an orphan and say this is by
Justice
he said this is about giving all parties
to the conflict an opportunity to share
in a new beginning whether you think
they deserve it or not I said would you
repeat that he said it's about giving
all parties to the conflict an
opportunity to share in and you
beginning whether you think they deserve
it or not and I said Brian I don't know
where you come from in terms of faith
since discovered its roots it's very
likely to any but I said the word we use
for that is grace profoundly deep
fundamental using fundamental in the
right sense theological concept
particularly for those of us who come
from within our tradition grace and he
said well if that is your word keep
reaching it because you're going to even
off a lot of it and it is a profoundly
fundamental theological concept with her
take away that and I certainly wouldn't
much left of anything because it's about
how God deals with us and how he asks us
to deal with each other the unworthiness
within ourselves and the unworthiness
that we may see in each other I so I
think I give that just as one of the
fundamental using that word in the
proper sense words theological that we
must hold to and not just think of us
out on paper now that's something we
live by and after this brief lesson in
one aspect of solitary theology let's
take about five minutes or so great